as we are heading towards the end of the
year we have some scholarships uh
available because uh the scholarships
are going to
be uninvalid for the new year with New
Year we will start with a new new uh
scholarships that we will be offering
for the winter programs but for now
there are few seats available very few
seats available because uh we recently
we are towards the end of the year and
uh there are some scholarships so there
here you can find out about all of this
in this link and also like you'll be
able to find out the payment process and
all of that here so uh and if you are
from developing countries and if you are
from low income countries you can
obviously reach out to us and if you
can't join the research fellowship
program and if you think that it is um
still a little expensive for you to
afford considering the condition that
you are in financial condition you are
in so in that case you can start with
the basic subscription which is like a
really really amazing thing for all of
us here who are learning by informatics
using bioinformatics because it's it's
just a ten dollar subscription that
allows you to access all the courses and
projects which are available on learn or
mixed logic it does not involve Mentor
guidance because that is impossible to
cover in that cost so the mental
guidance and project is what research
Fellowship is all about you can find out
check these payment links and reach out
to us for scholarships for research
fellowship program but if you can't do
it you should do this I would highly
recommend you to take the basic
subscription on T by info platform and
uh and start your research Journey
because in this subscription you will
get access to all the resources that we
have on omis logic learn which involves
the projects and all the tutorials also
so it helps you to do this on your own
and if when you're not sure or when you
are when you are don't have when you
have not enough time you know to do this
dedicatedly and you think that you would
start in maybe December or maybe in
January in that case you should do the
the take the subscription on almost
logic learn and start with the courses
here and in the courses you would be
able to do all those things that uh
vedika was talking about if I give you
an uh example of you know these coding
lessons you will find that there are
code blocks that you can run and learn
about coding which is both are in Python
very important in today's skill set
world looking which is being looked upon
by industry so here also you will be
able to run all of the pipelines so this
is our more tutorial based Hands-On
courses so these are not like typical
theoretical courses that you see other
way otherwise these are mostly Hands-On
courses which involves going through a
practical example going through a data
set so in this entire experience you
learn about how to how to interpret
analyze and what type of transcriptomics
or you know gene expression data is all
there so you learn about the history
what are the ways RNA can be Quantified
you're thinking you'll you're kind of
analyzing RNA so you you know about all
the things that could quantify RNA first
and then how big data like how Next
Generation sequencing is is helping in
several of these uh discoveries in
several of these uh products and all of
that so it it obviously there are some
other lessons that you would have to do
to learn about Advanced statistics and
machine learning but all of that is
included in the basic subscription which
is just for ten dollars so
um I think this is what I wanted to kind
of uh tell you all today uh if there are
any other questions so there are some
questions I can see in the chat what is
the difference between starter Education
and Research packages
so we have not started the uh
educational and research packages here
but yeah the research package is uh when
you have your own data which is
generated from your own lab and which is
not available on public repository so in
that case uh you you would have to
upload the data on rftp server and that
requires a research license so if you're
working for a research lab and you don't
want the data to be public and you want
to work on that confidentially so our
team enables that and we apply all the
data compliances and we help you with
the research per project so that's the
research monthly license to uh May to
access the Tiba info server and run with
your own data now educational which is
not as available right now is uh the
projects and courses which are developed
by industry experts so many of the
industry experts are working with us and
developing many cool projects really
really cool projects from Clinical
informatics to you know drug Discovery
so those will be available as we are
completing those and putting them on
learn so once they are available we will
have the educational 45 subscription
also available right now it's a great
opportunity because right now we don't
have all of this ready but we have the
starter subscription ready which has 36
courses I mean for ten dollars so I
these are these are courses that will
help you understand not about one
discipline but uh different types of
performix data analysis you will learn
about machine learning data science you
will learn about infectious diseases you
will learn about cancer cancer you you
can choose about all those
specializations which are also included
in this including microbiome research
and you know all of that so I mean
that's what uh it is and uh if there are
any further questions I will be happy to
answer those or else we will just
conclude this meeting and I will hope to
see you joining our programs and
interacting with us and going through
this almost logic Journey
over to you srigori for the conclusion
and then we can meet again